[Music]
foreign
[Music]
huge amounts of medical data are
generated across Europe every day
but much of this information isn't
maximized to its full potential
the European health data space launched
in May this year by the European
commission seeks to change that by
making Health Data more accessible to
both patients and medical professionals
there are two types of Health Data
data related to healthcare is known as
primary use
secondary use refers to information that
is processed under strict security and
confidentiality conditions for instance
in policy making or the Improvement of
healthcare products
sharing medical data is seen as one of
the best ways to foster growth in the
digital Health sector as it should
overcome the current fragmentation of
Health standards in Europe in Greece
organizations like the iag say common
specifications will promote business
opportunities
in the European market the e-health
sector and companies face various
obstacles
indeed the e-health sector constitutes a
fragmented market and that is to the
detriment of European citizens unlike
what happens in the United States and
Asia
currently worth around 40 billion euros
the European digital Healthcare Market
is on course to keep growing companies
like gnoman informatics a digital Health
Products Specialists say the coordinated
exchange of data would create a
europe-wide market benefiting both
patients and business
modeling medical data is vital for
European citizens as well as for the
rest of the world a patient can have all
their medical data and medical reports
on one device in this way they can have
the data with them when traveling
through different countries and they can
share that in any clinic and with any
doctor they want
improving interoperability between
Healthcare Providers across Europe
should also reduce duplication for
instance with medical tests that should
have a positive effect both on health
care costs and patient follow-up
[Music]
s
in terms of the architecture the use of
a European data space is the right
approach for e-health systems
it gives Direction enabling Europe to
create an electronic health industry and
offer quality services
linking medical and digital ecosystems
relies on interoperability allowing I.T
systems to read use and exchange data a
semantic data model will be key to
Bridging the terminology gap between
various Healthcare software systems The
Next Step will be to agree on sentence
structure with regard to how the
information is received
yeah
once fully implemented the European
health data space should open up
Europe's Health Market and enable small
and medium-sized firms to work with each
other to develop Innovative new products
[Music]